[musica]
t 2
Piace
[musica]
laboratorio voodoo
par
spina
A 200 tipi di viaggio
Gol di aprile
f 5
Gemma
buona scelta
bj
ch
Nessun viaggio
bl
vudù
di re
dj koo
Bravo collaboratore
Che carino
tee
vudù
[musica]
b Autore
el el
ragnatela
dee
pade
Cheni
ben
Hmm
ragnatela
[musica]
[applausi]
urlo
Bello
t merci
bejean
voodoo bon
pandano
b Merci
[musica]
dee merci
Oh
Avevo
Uuuuuuuudun
sto aspettando
Hmm
[applausi]
è
Guerra
dee solo
ch
tana
cap
Quattro giorni
Ehi
Elfo
avevo
dee dee
beni sbattuti
Abbastanza buono
me
Hmm
b 4
vendita diretta via web
tonnellata
[musica]
Alla guerra
di
Ehi
Quattro giorni
Ops
eh
merci di pena
Hmm
Cucciolo
dee dee jay
Derby Fi
Ah ah ah
[musica]
abbronzatura
Ah ah ah
Nero basso
Ranjeongti Rau è un dilet manutenzione Barria non facile Ra
[applausi]